wargames is mentioned certainly in the
ready player one book but I don't know
if it's in a film I haven't seen the
film yet what what was inside a ta T why
does it look remarkably like the front
of an altar because it was based on an
outer maybe the ATAC was a machine that
come out not long after the outer it's
an S 100 bus based machine so s 100
means that it had a connector I had a
backplane but there was a hundred
connections which carry the data bus
address bus and all the control lines
for the processor the backplane didn't
do anything it was just a bunch of
connectors you'd have a a CPU board
maybe a ram board maybe a cereal board
you could expand it so effectively it
was it was pretty much the same as the
Altair but it kind of looked nice with
its nice big switches a little bit sort
of PDP extol switches must be ones there
the LEDs that will light up on the front
so kind of a sexy-looking outer they
remind me of almost the front of an old
VCR yeah now I can see someone say
address some of them say data summit
some say input I mean what how does it
how would it work
you literally toggle in binary data and
the LEDs would light up on the panel
there with your binary output from it so
if you want to write data to address 0ff
then you would convert that into binary
you would toggle that binary in and then
you in the same way you would toggle in
the the data that goes there and that's
it so it's a very very time-consuming
but actually I mean everybody talks
about that in the way the Altair is down
and that is a very very slow and tedious
process but quite often what you would
be doing is just toggling a few lines of
code or maybe just a jump even that
would jump to a bit of code in memory
that would then initialize the disk
drive or the tape or whatever so bit of
book well they call boot loader code
just to jump the machine into life and
get it talking to its peripherals so
you've got the address bus there you can
set the address and then you've got your
data and you can toggle that in as well
and that way you can basically it's like
a poker command in basic you can poke
data into a certain memory location yes
you can use them like that but
ultimately these things you could have a
serial point if you had a serial port
you could hook up a terminal
you might have a rom in there which
might be basically a glow basically or
anything else maybe CPM from a disc tape
whatever interfaces you had connected to
it you could get your data in and out so
it's not like we all just sat there told
the Linnaean code day after day in
binary few people did but you know these
things were a bit more usable than that
I remember when we looked in the old
tear that we'll all sorts of upgrades
and changes and would that be quite
common on one of these as well that
people would just add their own
different boards yeah I mean these
machines wearing for enthusiasts you
know the people that were buying these
quite often were electronic see kind of
people so yeah you would buy one and you
would just keep making it better and the
same as everybody does with their PCs
you know more RAM more speed more power
it was exactly the same
so yeah the out there the original oil
teller we have isn't really much of an
out air left
you know it was upgraded so much this
one was a bit different it had a bigger
backplane in it so he's got a thin coat
his back playing there so he can plug in
more boards and you know same thing
would have been going on let's upgrade
it we need more RAM for our applications
yeah it looks to me like kind of quite a
professional machine so it's probably
bending reality to have had the hacker
kid with it sitting on his bookcase yeah
these things weren't cheap so you know
that they were you know reasonably good
money so whether Matthew Lightman his
name I think that's Broderick so
enlightened
like I remember was yeah it would have
afforded to have one of those machines
in his bedroom I don't know because it's
the machine it's just about to see a
picture their machine you've got the
terminal went next to it you have these
little speaker box so it could speak and
these VHS player on the shelf there
that's a fair amount of nothing's worth
of gear but maybe his parents were
loaded I don't know sir but there you go
maybe everyone I mean I mean were they
bending it there with things like the
speaker do you want to hear it so
welcome in what sort of hardware would
you have needed to have made a computer
of that era talk I mean there was basics
but you said this is out there so it's
it's feasible make mistakes yes
maybe it spoke a bit better than the
actual real speech synthesizers did at
the time I mean I can't remember when
the spo2 five six came out which is a
chip which is a space since you were
linking those up to Ernie's xat ones and
things but I mean speech synthesis has
been around some time so it was kind of
feasible maybe normally on communal we
get the lid off we have a look around
but this particular ones being referred
yeah so this one is some bit of an empty
shell at the minute so we have one of
our volunteers has kindly taken the
boards out and it's getting them working
so we've got there's a processor carded
a RAM card the s100 is pretty standard
so he can test it in other machines the
Altair he's already done so we now will
very shortly have an out there where you
can well you could toggle in the data if
you want but we probably won't but we
will be able to load in the little
program to just fill up with timing
loops and as those timing looks play
interferes with the radio the radio then
creates tones and you've got music and
apparently there was this sort of award
given for the first thing that they
really made an outer hair do of any use
if you call they have any use but ax
music or some is um so yeah it so
that'll be working but also the next
thing is getting in so I work as well so
we're just getting the balls done then
we'll refurbish the machine itself
hopefully you'd better come here and
have a play and we can take it to that
gate because it's yellow key yellow
castle and we can get in there now we
have what could possibly be a sword or
maybe just an arrow so we can now take
that one and we can come out is it one
thing at a time
yeah yeah so you've got to have the
right things at the right time so we can
go this way all but we can't